.
CURRENT AMERICAN LEADERSHIP
ISN'T JUST SABOTAGING THE
COUNTRY ABROAD BUT WITHIN AS
WELL.
THE MAINSTREAMING OF POT TEST,
THE SAME TIME AS THE DRUG HAS
INCREASED EXPONENTIALLY IN ITS
POTENCY, ITS THC LEVELS.
AS ONE HIGHLY CITED PAPER POINTS
OUT, THE CONSUMPTION OF
MARIJUANA IS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
INCREASE IN VIOLENT BEHAVIOR AND
A HIGH RISK OF PSYCHOSIS FOR
FREQUENT USERS.
THESE ISSUES ARE NOT OF CONCERN
LOOK INTO THOSE TO CASH IN ON
THIS BURGEONING BUSINESS.
DOCUMENTS OBTAINED BY THE
"L.A. TIMES" SHOW THAT CANNABIS
COMPANIES AND INVESTORS PROVIDED
SOME OF THE EARLY FINANCIAL
SUPPORT FOR UCLA'S CANNABIS
RESEARCH INITIATIVE.
THEY FUNDED IT.
WRITING CHECKS FOR TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN
DONATIONS AND ASSISTING WITH
FUND-RAISING EVENTS.
THEY AREN'T ALONE.
HARVARD, MIT, UC SAN DIEGO ARE
AMONG THE SCHOOLS THAT ARE
ACCEPTED MULTIMILLION DOLLAR
GIFTS IN RECENT YEARS.
JOINING ME NOW IS LUKE,
EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENT OF
SMART APPROACHES TO MARIJUANA.
LUKE, THE RESEARCH FOR HOW SAFE
AND GREAT WEED IS, SOME OF THE
DOLLARS ARE COMING FROM THE LEAD
LOBBY.
ARE WE GETTING THIS RIGHT?
>> YEAH, THANKS FOR HAVING ME
ON.
BIG MARIJUANA IS TERRIFIED.
THERE ARE VOLUMES OF RESEARCH
TELLING US THAT THIS NEW
SUPERCHARGED MARIJUANA THAT THE
INDUSTRY IS PUMPING OUT IS
CAUSING PSYCHOSIS,
SCHIZOPHRENIA.
WE ARE SEEING ADDICTION RATES GO
UP, THEY ARE TARGETING OUR KIDS,
CAR CRASHES ON THE ROADS.
ALL THIS IS COMING OUT IN THE
RESEARCH SO THEY GO TO THEIR BIG
BROTHER TOBACCO WHO, BY THE WAY,
IS THEIR BIGGEST INVESTOR AND
THEY START PUMPING OUT FAKE,
BOGUS RESEARCH.
ONE OF THE PEOPLE THAT FUNDED
THE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOR
UCLA'S RESEARCH ON MARIJUANA,
THAT COMPANY WAS CALLED NUGS.
NOT RUN BY SIR ISAAC NEWTON.
THEY ARE NOT TRYING TO ADVANCE
SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH, THEY ARE
PLAYING FOR PUBLICITY AND
MISINFORMATION WHICH IS EXACTLY
WHAT BIG TOBACCO DID.
THEY KILLED MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS TO MAKE A BUCK AND
THAT'S WHAT MARIJUANA WANTS TO
DO WITH THEIR BIG TOBACCO
INVESTORS.
>> Laura: IT IS CORRUPT TO THE
CORE.
YOU CHAT WITH FOLKS WHO MAYBE
DON'T READ UP ON THIS OR HAVEN'T
REALLY FOLLOWED WHAT HE DOES,
ESPECIALLY TO THE YOUNG BRAIN
WITH FREQUENT USE, THEY SAY IT'S
BETTER FOR YOU THAN ALCOHOL.
IT RELAXES YOU.
ALL THE MEDICINAL BENEFITS.
TO THAT, YOU SAY?
>> WHEN I HEAR ABOUT THE ALCOHOL
THING, I SAY IF YOU HAVE A CAR
AND YOU JUST BROKE YOUR
HEADLIGHT, DO YOU SAY OKAY, TO
BE CONSISTENT, LET ME SMASH IN
MY TAILLIGHT?
WE HAVE ISSUES WITH ALCOHOL.
MORE THAN 100,000 AMERICANS DIE
EVERY YEAR RELATED TO ALCOHOL.
IT'S NOT LIKE THAT'S GOING
GREAT.
IF YOU LOOK AT MARIJUANA, YOU
HAVE THE INDUSTRY PEDDLING THESE
LIES.
MARIJUANA HELPS WITH ANXIETY.
WE HAVE TEN RESEARCH STUDIES
THAT JUST CAME OUT IN THE LAST
FIVE YEARS THAT TELL YOU
MARIJUANA ACTUALLY MAKES ANXIETY
WORSE.
YOU HEAR THESE CLAIMS, MARIJUANA
IS NOT ADDICTIVE THAT THE DATA
ARE TELLING US FROM OUR NATIONS
AND MOST REVERED RESEARCHERS
THAT ONE IN THREE PEOPLE WHO USE
MARIJUANA IN THE LAST YEAR WILL
DEVELOP A CANNABIS USE DISORDER.
THAT'S THE MEDICAL DIAGNOSIS FOR
ADDICTION.
THERE IS THESE MYTHS THAT THE
INDUSTRY IS TRYING TO UNDERMINE
YOUR WE NEED REAL SCIENCE, NOT
BOGUS SCIENCE.
>> Laura: IT REMINDS ME A LOT
OF THE COVERT, YOU KNOW FUNDING,
OF RESEARCH STUDIES WITH COVID.
IT REMINDS ME A LOT OF THA